off the southern coast of Thailand time
is running out for rescuers this pilot
whale is stranded starving to death if
the team leave it it will drown it
cannot eat because its stomach is full
of plastic when the will still alive on
the last day with his choking and he
wanted the plastic back for four or five
uses for five days they protect it from
the elements desperate to save its life
but the damage is too great these
pictures after its death show the 80
plastic bags found inside the whale
eight kilograms of human waste slowly
killing it the cannot go to DA in his
high sword the animal cannot get any
nutrients on the board and I'm not sure
the Parsee have attitude and sometime
the pasta additive is a poison order
he's a hostage for the animals this
problem isn't limited to Asia in Norway
skies ocean rescue campaign also filmed
a whale with a stomach full of plastic
but Thais still use a huge amount of
free carrier bags so the government's
considering bringing in new charges if
the 7/11 or the department store
everywhere and government it should have
a policy like when you want to the
plastic you should pay it it will help a
lot rescuers know this whale won't be
the longest with 8 million tons of bags
and bottles clogging up her oceans more
animals will die only drastic action
will turn around the world's plastic
tide Siobhan Robbins Sky News Bangkok
well do find out more about sky is ocean
campaign and find out how you can get
involved yourself at sky and rescue calm